let's talk about the adrenal fatigue
diet another name for that would be the
adrenal body type diet I talked
extensively about that in my book the
healthy keto plan which has been through
several additions and updates and today
I'm going to explain the latest version
so you have all the details now why
would someone do the adrenal fatigue
diet in the first place well first of
all they might have adrenal fatigue or
they did the keto plan
they did the intermittent fasting but
the results are just not what they
intended I created different plans based
on body type so there's an adrenal body
type there's a liver body type there's
an ovary body type and there's a thyroid
body type so all four body types who
come after someone did the basic plan
but only if they're not getting results
so what is the dream fatigue diet it's
additional steps to improve your results
okay
when would you do it after two weeks
okay you did it for two weeks
results aren't perfect boom you actually
apply what I'm gonna show you so I'm
gonna explain how to do it next but this
diet plan helps reset and will help
increase the recovery the unique thing
about the adrenal gland is that it's a
stress gland and if you take a look at
all the book different body types this
is the most common simply because an
average person goes through a tremendous
amount of stress and then adrenal takes
a beating and the cortisol is stimulated
over and over and over a person becomes
in flight or flight mode they stress out
and now the adrenal hormones are pumping
out more hormones than they need to over
a long period of time and that basically
makes the person not just tired but it
decreases their ability to recover and
heal and especially lose weight so
they're not going to be able to lose
weight that well especially in the
midsection
so I'm going to show you how to
tailor-make it after the two weeks so
the first thing to do is do healthy keto
and in termina fasting if you're new to
my channel I put a link down below of
how to do that this is very very
important that you get the basics in
healthy keto and in a minute fasting for
two weeks you may not need to do this if
this works and I
say this is very very successful so you
might find that you don't need to do
anything else
just do this plan right here it's gonna
be low-carb 20 to 50 grams of carbs per
day or less moderate protein between
three to six ounces of protein per meal
high-quality protein like eggs fish
grass-fed grass-finished beef things
like that or lamb okay
high fat okay we're talking about a
hundred grams to 130 grams now I don't
want you to calculate this with a scale
or anything like that the fat really
makes up 70% of the calories so I'm
gonna recommend that you watch my video
on this to get more data and examples of
what this looks like because I don't
want to make it complex okay so at this
point don't worry about this you can get
further details in the next video okay
vegetables we don't count vegetable
carbohydrates but you want to have at
least seven cups - 10 cups my wife and I
went to lunch at two different
restaurants and I was shocked to find
out that the salads that they brought us
were huge I'm talking they were at least
eight cups I think my wife Sal was 10
cups of salad I was like amazed so
apparently there are places that you can
go we can get more salad versus this
little tiny side one cup or a cup and a
half of salad which doesn't really do
anything but we want the vitamins
vitamin C folate minerals in the
vegetables okay so this is the basic
plan right through here and then we want
to combine this with something called
venom in the fasting okay so typically
someone is consuming a breakfast okay
breakfast comes from the word break fast
you're breaking the fast with the first
meal so you're fasting all that long and
then you're going to break the fast
first thing we do if you have three
meals you simply do this okay as you
lower the carb and you increase the fat
the need for a snack will go away so
you're able to go from one meal to the
next without eating anything or snacking
because you never want to snack or eat
if you're not hungry okay
so three meals okay and then nothing
between so you're fasting you do that
for a little bit all of a sudden you're
not hungry in the morning so don't eat
this breakfast in the morning if you're
not hungry okay so just let yourself go
you can drink coffee whatever and then
you go as long as you can so it might
take a little bit before you cannot go
to noon and have your first meal okay I
like my first meal it's really like eggs
and bacon and things like that it's like
my breakfast because I don't need a
breakfast I just push it all the way to
here now what happens over time as you
do this you're gonna start becoming
adapted to ketones and then you want to
take your lunch and your dinner and
squish them together a little bit so
there's like four hour window and that
will give you a 20 hour fast which is a
good amount of fasting to produce some
amazing results now a lot of people go
to one meal a day some people stick with
for four hours and they're eating window
some people actually need to do at lunch
and six but the point is we want to
start doing in a minute fasting and
combine that with out the ketosis it's
gonna help the adrenals but let's say
for example you do this for two weeks
and your results are not fantastic okay
this is what you're gonna do you're
going to adjust the protein you're gonna
increase the protein to maybe seven
ounces maybe eight ounces maybe even
nine ounces per meal why because with
the adrenal hormones you're gonna get an
excessive amount of breakdown it's
called a catabolic effect
Drina hormones break down muscle protein
and it can even break down your own
protein so if you're in the state of
high adrenal hormone cortisol and you're
breaking down muscle protein we want to
replace that with protein so we want to
increase a little bit more protein per
meal that will help you the second thing
you want to adjust the fat
believe it or not a lot of people are
not consuming enough fat okay so just
what the adrenals want to make sure that
we keep the fat on the high side avocado
the fat in yolks coconut oil things like
that we do not want to do a low fat diet
because your adrenal hormones are made
from fat okay so we need more fat to
support the adrenals butter is another
source of fat the kid number three the
key nutrients for the adrenal fatigue
diet or any adrenal body time would be
vitamin b1 this is very very very
important simply because the more stress
you go through the more you burn up a
vitamin b1 in fact you'll be quite
shocked when you take this and I like to
get it from nutritional yeast because
it's a really good source and I have
these tablets and I chew them when you
take this within about three to four
minutes you're gonna feel a sense of
relief the nervous tension will go away
excessive thinking thinking it goes away
so nutritional use will really help the
adrenals and a big way vitamin C a lot
of the vitamin C in your body is stored
in the adrenal and you need that to make
adrenal hormones so when someone has
adrenal fatigue they're usually the
really deficient in vitamin C okay so
you take more about them and see make
sure you if you take vitamin C it's
based on whole foods or food
concentrates sauerkraut is loaded with
vitamin C bell peppers loaded with
vitamin C vegetables have a lot of
vitamin C but realize that most of the
vitamin C supplements are made with
synthetics I just recommend avoid that
because sometimes they make it from
sulfuric acid and corn starch together
chemically to make this ascorbic acid
well that's a very big difference from
the vitamin C you would get from food
okay potassium really really important
with the adrenals simply because the
more adrenal fatigue you have the least
amount of potassium you're going to have
potassium supports your adrenals and by
the way if you have adrenal fatigue and
you're trying to lose weight your body
will have a tendency to be more alkaline
than acidic which is very interesting
and this is why apple cider vinegar is
really good to take if you have this
specific issue so you can do
electrolytes you can do a food base
patency but these are the three most
important nutrients to help with the
situation
the type of exercise you want to do
hour-long walks I'm talking like an hour
outside getting in nature without
anything like [__] in your cell phone
just getting space vital vital to get
enough oxygen to actually reduce the
stress on your dreams and the last thing
is a stress technique which I developed
it's in my book you can also find it on
one of my videos which is called the
stress webinar so I put links down below
and on this page so that way you have
all the information to address adrenal
fatigue and target the adrenal body type